Well, look what we have here.
If this is our pendulum and this is our pivot point,
when I pull back the pendulum it's going to trace out this circle.
Now, of course, I'm constraining myself to small angles,
so let's get rid of most of that circle.
But when I pull back my pendulum by angle of θ,
let's say this pendulum has some length L that's the distance from here to here.
We can do the same sort of ratio that we did way back in Unit 1
when we were measure the circumference of the earth.
This angle θ, when compared to the entire angle of the circle, 2π radians,
is in the same ratio as this arc length, which I'm going to call x,
to the entire circumference of the circle, which is 2π times the radius or L.
If this isn't clear, let me just explain this one more time.
What I'm saying is the ratio of this angle to the entire 360° or 2π radians of a circle.
That's identical to the ratio of this distance to the total circumference.
This angle to the total angle is the same as this distance to the total distance.
What I'm trying to do is replace this θ, so I'm going to solve for θ.
When I do, I get θ = x/L. Now we're making progress.
Let's see what happens.
Now I have that a is equal to -g(x/L), having made that replacement.
Or put another way, a - -g/L(x)--minus something times x.
We have simple harmonic motion in our pendulum. Wonderful.
Now, I'm going to ask you a very hard question,
because it's going to have you put together a lot of the things we've been talking about.
We're trying to design a clock. We want a period of 1 second.
I want to know how long should our pendulum be if we want a period of 1 second?
Don't forget that this something here becomes ω².
Enter your answer here in meters.